many people ask me questions about stoic
philosophy and practice I've created
this series to provide short answers to
the most common recurring or confusing
questions about stoicism how do these
Stoics define happiness this is an
excellent question which gets asked
continually whether in discussion forums
or presentations or meetings on stoicism
and as it so happens it's a question
that there is and answer for because the
Stoics did in fact define happiness now
it's a little bit more complex than
giving one single straightforward
formula which is what the person is
often looking for because the Stoics
also gave a number of complimentary
characterizations each of which is is
equivalent to a definition of what they
conceived of as happiness before we
start looking at some of the answers
that the Stoics were in fact giving
consistently throughout the development
of their school about what happiness is
we need to be clear about the terms that
are being used because in our modern
context many people associate happiness
with a momentary emotion or mood that
they're feeling something fleeting
something that you enjoy just for a
brief period of time and that's not what
the ancients actually meant when they
use the terms that we nowadays translate
as happiness
so in Greek the term is owed ammonia
which doesn't translate exactly as
happiness but as is close enough being
of good spirit it's a lasting sort of
affective condition that one is in but
it's more than just a feeling it has to
do with fulfillment of one's entire life
across the spectrum in Latin it's
beatitude oh and this is important
because we
you see Seneca talking about that as
well as Cicero so we're going to be
relying on this particular conception
going forward
we're not thinking about happiness as
just something that we experience for a
moment it's something that we would aim
for as the Stoics call it as an end as a
goal as the purpose of human life as I
mentioned just earlier the Stoics
provided multiple characterizations of
happiness
each of these is understood to be a
definition to tell us what happiness
actually does consist in now why did
they give multiple definitions or
characterizations well because there are
numerous different aspects all of which
are connected with each other for what
they are calling a Damania beatitude oh
and what we call happiness so one of
them that Zeno gives right at the start
that I think a lot of people have
gravitated to and which we see Epictetus
himself later on bringing up is a smooth
flow of life happiness consists in a
smooth flowing an ongoing process of
living several other characterizations
or definitions of happiness are there
right from the start for the Stoics and
they include living in accordance with
nature and having and acting on and
cultivating the virtues so these are
both just as important as this notion of
flow and you can understand these as
correlative to each other by developing
by acting upon by valuing the virtues
these these great states of character or
human excellence as that which really
matters the most that which has to be
given the top priority one will enjoy
happiness and it's not simply as a
result of virtue to be virtuous
to live virtuously is to be happy for
the Stoics the Stoics viewed themselves
as differing from some of the other
virtue ethicists of their own time in
laying this almost exclusive emphasis
upon the sufficiency of virtue to make
us happy
by contrast to some of the other schools
who said well you need some other goods
as well in order to be truly happy the
stomach said no by cultivating virtue by
living in that way by behaving in that
way you will in fact enjoy the pinnacle
of human happiness virtue and what is
right in itself is the primary good now
one of the later Stoics Seneca actually
wrote an entire treatise on the happy
life and if you look at part 4 of it you
see him talking about the ways in which
we can define the happy life which
allows us to define happiness and it
tells us that it can be defined in in
multiple ways precisely because of not
how complex but how interconnected the
parts or not even parts aspects of
happiness are he says our highest good
may also be defined otherwise that is to
say the same idea may be expressed in
different language and he gives a
metaphor just as the same army can be
expanded and contracted we can do the
same thing with our conceptions with our
language we can direct it towards virtue
towards flow towards living in
accordance with nature towards
fulfilling our duties towards all these
other things that fit into the notion of
happiness and it does give us a nice
characterization there by saying we can
define it in multiple ways here's one
way that we can define happiness we can
say that man is happy who knows bad and
good only in the form of good or bad
minds who worships or celebrates honor
and is satisfied with
virtue who is neither puffed up by good
fortune nor cast down by evil fortune
who knows no other good than that which
he is able to bestow upon himself whose
real pleasure lies in despising
pleasures there's a lot involved in that
but this brings up another key aspect of
the stoic conception and indeed
definition of happiness which is
self-sufficiency the stoic aims at
living a life which is not going to be
entangled with things outside of one's
control which then could impinge upon
one's happiness to be happy involves
freedom involves not being troubled by
things involves having the capacity to
determine for oneself how to act what to
choose what to follow so all of these
are very important aspects of the stoic
conception of happiness this answers the
question of how do the Stoics define
happiness it's worth repeating that the
definitions that they give are plural
but they're all converging upon the same
basic idea I think it could be useful to
bring this to a close to talk about some
of the places where you can go to find
out more about this I mentioned Senecas
on the happy life and that's a great
source you're also going to find many
discussions of happiness within his
letters and you might also look at
Epictetus and some of his discussions
particularly early on in the discourse
is about what makes us happy what would
allows us to have eudaimonia that is
happiness or freedom or not being
bothered is one way of translating
anoxia another place to look would be
Cicero's treatise where it's actually a
dialogue on the ends or sometimes it's
translated on moral ends de finibus you
want to look at book 3 where the stoic
school
the stoic conceptions of things are
being presented in the character of Kato
then a third place that could be
particularly useful would be to go to
Diogenes Laertes lives that the
philosophers look at the life of Zeno in
book seven you'll find some discussion
of the doctrines of the Stoics and then
the final place that I would direct you
to is arias didymus is epitome of stoic
ethics where there is a very clear
discussion about how the Stoics defined
happiness from Zeno onward if you found
this answer helpful for you then please
share it with others who might benefit
from it this work is entirely supported
by crowdfunding on my patreon site so if
you find it valuable
consider becoming a supporter at
patreon.com slash Saddler